hey 42 here in 1919 young ambitious 30
year old stood in a beer hall in Munich
Germany and gave a passionate speech
about politics to 111 attendees only
four months later the same young man
gave another speech but this time due to
word of mouth his audience had grown to
over 2,000 people a few months later he
gave another speech with 6000 devotees
in attendance this is how revolutions
begin that's ambitious young man went on
to change the world beyond recognition
by committing countless atrocities
against a human race and attempting
genocide yes I am talking about adult
Hitler do not take my words as praise
but there is no doubt that Hitler's
oration abilities are unrivaled
throughout history his ability to
persuade others and bring them into his
cause and align their ideals with his
own were powerful beyond belief during
1/2 hour speech in 1920 he was
completely interrupted 58 times by fun
during applause and cheers from the
crowd but was Adolf Hitler
a great leader absolutely not
effective maybe but great know as humans
with a conscience we define great as
doing good
therefore a great leader must use their
power and influence for good not evil as
Hitler did but besides the obvious
deplorable reasons that Hitler was not a
great leader he wasn't actually good at
leading let me explain Hitler was a
fantastic orator he gave speeches so
powerful so intense they made you forget
your own morals and follow him into a
genocide all abyss
he was extremely effective at collecting
followers and power but being able to
rally hearts and minds is only one-half
of being a great leader for once Hitler
had to duck
he was hopeless at putting it to use at
least when you compare him to his
wartime competition a truly great leader
in Hitler's position of immense power
would have leveraged Germany strengths
and turned wartime Germany into a true
superpower a force to be reckoned with
and a true leader could have done so
without ever going to war using goalie
diplomacy and leverage but alas Hitler
was too consumed by his own hate and
pride his deep hatred of Jews communists
and others caused him to get distracted
by and drawn into many futile conflicts
that's work completely unnecessary and
only hindered Germany's overall strength
such as Stalingrad he was more concerned
with destroying his neighboring
countries and focusing on the strength
of his own Germany these are certainly
not the traits of a great leader just a
passionate angry fool are you passionate
about something but tired of feeling
like a fool I'd like to take a minute to
thank Skillshare for sponsoring this
video
Skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of classes and
design business technology and more
Premium Membership gives you unlimited
access to high-quality classes on must
know topics so you can improve your
skills unlock new opportunities and do
the work you love if you're thinking of
starting a business or want to start a
new project with other people then
you'll need to become a great leader
yourself some of the greatest leaders in
history have also been the greatest
orators Barack Obama Winston Churchill
Martin Luther King to name but a few and
to sharpen up your public speaking
skills I can't recommend highly enough
the Skillshare course presentation
essentials how to share ideas that
inspire action and good news if you're
one of the first 1000 people to use the
promo link in a description you will get
your first two months of Skillshare
premium for just 99 cents after that
skill share is more affordable than most
learning platforms out there at only $10
per month
click the link in the description to
check out Simon's to next court and
thousands of others
but remember only the first 1000 people
will get two months for 99 cents
speaking of Winston Churchill Hitler's
wartime opponent is thought of as one of
history's most powerful leaders but
unlike Hitler many people go as far as
to call Churchill a great leader so
what's the difference is Churchill only
a great leader and Hitler is not because
Churchill was fighting for good not evil
well that certainly helps but it's the
reason why Churchill was fighting for
good which made him a truly great leader
and that reason is a great empathy for
his people
Hitler's motivation for going to war was
occupation of neighboring countries to
expand the German Empire and his idea of
a pure race and also genocide I don't
need to tell you that these are selfish
reasons
Hitler's powerful oration may have
tricked millions into believing that he
had the German people's best interests
in mind but in truth his motivations
were not only selfish but driven by
delusions insecurities and mental
insanity
Churchill's motivations were the polar
opposite he went to war to defend his
people and his country from the tyranny
of evil he had no desire to invade and
capture over lands or to enslave and
murder innocent people psychologists
have long studied what it takes to be a
great leader and they have all converged
on what key quality that every great
leader from history shared one mental
attributes that separates Churchill from
Hitler and that is emotional
intelligence it is not intellect cunning
or physical prowess that makes a great
leader it is emotional intelligence that
is the ability to sympathise with others
to know how people think behave and how
they will react given any situation
what made Abraham Lincoln such a great
leader such an icon respected throughout
the ages how was he able to overcome the
tremendous challenges in abolishing
slavery well quite simply he possessed
more emotional intelligence
than his enemies whilst the plantation
owners and leaders of the Confederacy
were only concerned with monetary gain
from their slaves
Lincoln was able to sympathize with the
plight of the slaves he could humanize
them and this gave him the drive the
passion the motivation to put every
fiber of himself into his quest to set
them free and that he did Hitler may
have been an extremely intelligent man
an incredible orator and powerfully
persuasive but he had not a scrap of
emotional intelligence
he had no sympathy no man who did the
things that he did could possess these
qualities but Churchill despite his
image as a pragmatic Bulldog did and
that is why he led Britain and the world
to victory but being a great leader
isn't just about being able to make the
correct decision a truly great leader
must also be able to make the hardest
decision of all when it is most needed
of them no matter the cost
on the 10th of May 1940 Winston
Churchill was appointed Prime Minister
of Great Britain on the very same day
Hitler launched a huge invasion of
France occupying vast waves of the
country before long Hitler's army had
occupied Paris and forced a nation of
France to surrender when Churchill heard
that France was prepared to surrender
and make a peace deal with Hitler he
knew that if the Nazis were to get their
hands on France's Navy which at the time
was the second most powerful in the
world after Britain's then Britain would
be screwed
sure Britain's Navy was powerful but
with the combined might of France's Navy
and Germany's u-boats Britain would have
been Hitler's for the taking and worse
yet if Hitler took Britain and its Navy
the rest of the world would have stood
no chance against the spread of Hitler's
tyranny we've all like combined military
might he could have taken the u.s. with
ease and today the world would be under
Nazi rule simply because Hitler got his
hands on a few French warships
Churchill could absolutely not let this
happen initially he wrote to the US
president FDR and asked if he could
borrow 50 of their older warships to
defend Britain in the events that Hitler
did take Francis Navy but FDR was too
concerned with winning the upcoming
election and so denied Churchill's
request
even after Churchill wrote back to him
explaining that if Britain was taken
then America would be next
the French Admiral had already made a
promise to Churchill that if the Nazis
did ever try to take Frances warships
then the French would sabotage their own
ships rendering them useless to Hitler
it sounds fair enough but Churchill was
too pragmatic to rely solely on the
French disabling their own ships and so
he formulated a grand plan called
Operation catapult the most daring and
most morally difficult plan that
Churchill had so far enacted France his
vast Navy were spread out in fleets
around the world
so Churchill plan to use espionage
stealth and if necessary force to
capture all of france's warships and
relocate them to British waters so on
the 3rd of July 1940 operation catapult
was launched and simultaneous takeovers
of every French Navy vessel took place
within a few hours around the globe
bearing in mind that until now France
was Britain's closest ally during the
war this must have been a horrendously
difficult decision for Churchill to make
but the decision that he had to make in
just a few hours time would be many
times more difficult in fact it would be
the most difficult the most
heart-wrenching decision that the prime
minister would make his entire life a
decision that many historians have since
said who is one of the biggest turning
points of the war unchanged a fate of
the world
you see all but one of the fleets within
the French Navy could be taken with
little effort by simply sneaking British
servicemen on board and putting a gun up
to the captain but one fleet the most
powerful and most heavily guarded within
France's Navy would not be so simple in
the harbor of Mel's al-kabir in french
algeria france had moored their four
largest and most powerful ships de
bretagne province Strasbourg and Dunkirk
as well as some smaller destroyers
if Hitler got his hands on just this
fleet alone it would spell the end of
the war for Britain and the world
Churchill wrote an ultimatum to the
French admiral and sent out a fleet of
the Royal Navy's most powerful vessels
to deliver it to the French fleet
admiral Kabira it gave France just six
hours from receiving a letter to say all
a large fleet of warships to Britain or
America and surrender them to the
British Navy otherwise the British Navy
would regrettably sink them using force
the Royal Navy surrounded the French
fleet and the long intense standoff wore
on for many hours as a French admiral
refused to peacefully surrender their
ships to the British their allies the
French admiral was annoyed that
Churchill obviously didn't trust his
promise that the French Navy would
destroy their own ships if the Nazis
tried to take them
he was also annoyed that's a lower
ranking member of the Royal Navy was
sent to deliver Churchill's ultimatum to
him instead of someone higher up in the
command he also didn't quite believe
that the British would actually fire
upon them if they refused to hand over
the ships so with the friendship of all
remaining stubborn the two supposedly
allied nation stood gun to gun across
the harbor in a Mexican standoff a few
hours later the french admiral called on
nearby backup just in case the british
did decide to open fire but the british
soon caught wind of this approaching
backup and so the captain sent a
telegram informing Churchill of the
upcoming French backup only minutes away
Churchill was suddenly weighed down by
his worst fear
that it would have to come to this the
possibility of ordering the British to
shoot upon their own allies with little
time to think he sent back a short sharp
reply settle matters quicker and that
was it knowing full well what that might
entail regrettably the British fleet
knew what they had to do next as
Churchill had briefed them beforehand
yet the British signaled to friendship
once more giving their one last warning
come to an agreement within 30 minutes
or we will open fire
a 554 p.m. no agreement had been reached
and sure enough the British pointed
their cannons at the French vessels and
began to fire the Royal Navy fleet that
day consisted of battleships HMS valiant
and HMS resolution an aircraft carrier
and several destroyers but at the helm
of the fleet was the Royal Navy's most
powerful weapon
HMS caught the largest and most powerful
warship in the world at that time
completely unmatched by any other ship
her huge turrets fired relentlessly upon
the French battleships sinking one of
them and completely destroying the
others within minutes 1297 French
servicemen lost their lives that day at
the hands of the British
supposedly their closest ally whilst a
British public in government were
entirely supportive of Churchill's
decision when they found out what had
happened many of us around the world
obviously in France were both critical
and upset at Britain's actions that day
seeing it as a betrayal now it could be
argued that Churchill's move to sink the
French Navy was over-the-top and rash or
perhaps evil but one has to consider
what the other outcome would have been
if Hitler had got his hands on those
French battleships it is entirely
possible that the entire world not just
Britain would be under Nazi rule today
it is reported that when word got back
to Churchill in London about
had happened in mers-el-kébir and how
many friends servicemen had been killed
Churchill was physically sick and broke
down in tears whether you agree with
operation catapult or not and no one can
argue how incomprehensibly difficult a
decision of that magnitude must have
been for Churchill or any other leader
for that matter
Churchill sacrificed over a thousand of
Britain's closest allies that day to
save the British people and potentially
save the world from the tyranny of evil
a horrible decision to make with a
referable consequences but if that's not
true leadership then I don't know what
is Winston Churchill was recently voted
by the British public as the greatest
Briton of all time and sure it's
tremendously easy to see how he was a
great leader he stared pure evil in the
face when the rest of his cabinet wanted
to surrender
he led Britain and Western Europe
through its darkest hour he was a master
of the English language and used it to
inspire and uplift the morale of the
British people but how come there are
some leaders today that are considered
by their people as great whilst the rest
of the world can only see the opposite
it used to be that good and evil was so
black and white you would look at the
world stage and the vast differences
between the goodies and their buddies
and it was laid out there for all to see
but today our leaders are becoming
evermore gray treading a thin line
between good and evil leaders such as
Donald Trump and kim jongwan are so
polarizing yet so murky sure leaders
have always had supporters and
detractors but in today's information
world it's so easy to find out why
supposedly bad leaders do the things
that they do instead of relying on the
propaganda and with nobody it's the
balance between good and evil more
murkier harder to understand that move
lad Emir Putin
you cannot talk about great leaders
without talking about supposedly the
most powerful man in the world Putin for
nobody is more loved by their own people
okay maybe Kim jong-un is but under
entirely different circumstances let's
say every single week an army of
pollsters traverses the eleven different
time zones of Russia and knocks on the
doors of every single house in the
country asking their opinion of Vladimir
Putin according to these polls Vladimir
Putin's approval rating by his own
people is a staggering 83 percent and
that has not dropped below 80 percent
since 2014 and these numbers aren't
artificially inflated by the Kremlin
several independent Western polling
companies have done similar polls and
always arrive around the same number she
put that into perspective
Trump's approval rating is half of that
at 40 percent
Theresa Mays is around 43 percent and
Angela Merkel's is around 50 percent at
the time of writing this video but how
can this be
doesn't most of the West's view Putin as
a bad guy or a troublemaker at the very
least and it's easy to see why that is
Putin has done some rather questionable
and immoral things including annexing
Crimea waging a war on the LGBT
community he is suspected of having
critics and political enemies killed and
the most questionable act of all he is
of course rumored to have used hacking
campaigns and propaganda to make trump
president but no matter how much Western
politicians and Western media demonizes
him his approval ratings even motherland
Russia just keep increasing with time to
appreciate why we have to understand the
vast difference in culture between
Russia and the West
Russians respect strength whilst Western
Europeans may have ideals such as fair
democracy social equality and justice it
is ingrained within the Russian culture
to never show
weakness Russians strive for the
solidification and strengthening of
their own nation they have a great
respect for Russia and any president who
can make Russia appear to be strong and
not a pushover on the world stage is no
doubt going to be popular Putin does
exactly that the propaganda released
from the Kremlin is carefully curated to
always show Putin in positions of
strength in manly pursuits like fishing
topless hunting topless and riding a
shark
I mean horse topless there seems to be a
theme here these are not candid holiday
snaps these are carefully curated to
show Putin in his best and strongest
light he appears formidable and able to
take on whatever the West throws at him
Putin may not play so nicely on the
global stage but whether you sympathize
with Putin's methods of politics or not
he is in his own way for the Russian
people at least a great leader leaders
come in many forms throughout history
some have led us into the darkest abyss
all of us have led us to victory but one
thing that all great leaders do is bring
about change within the world and leave
their own unique footprint on the future
sometimes for the best sometimes for the
worst so wherever you are in the world
when the time next comes for you to
choose a leader
make your choice worthwhile thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video then
please click here to support me on
patreon if you haven't already don't
forget to subscribe and I just like to
thank Skillshare one more time for
sponsoring this video don't forget to
check them out by clicking the link in
the description